[Music]
hey guys welcome back demo rpg episode
six
and we are gonna code up this
next part c plus plus so uh it's
intended either for i guess your
entertainment or your learning or if
you're following along then awesome any
of those are great now i will say just
right off the bat here there's an
outtake of this episode as i was gonna
do what i'm about to do in a different
way but i think it's going to be more
complicated that way so i'm scrapping
that episode and we're going to go a
different direction but if you want to
see it if you're at the supporter level
here on the channel you can join or uh
we're on patreon
uh it's uh three bucks a month helps
support the channel and me making these
productions and keeping going i'll post
that episode over there and uh so just
throwing that out there and i always
appreciate everybody's support even if
it's just watching hitting the like
button whatever it is all right so today
we are going to introduce some level
trees now we're just going to keep it
really simple because there's a lot i
want to do with this but it gets really
complicated really fast and requires a
lot of extra code because originally i
was thinking i wanted to do three
different kinds of abilities
triggered abilities where something
happens and your ability kind of
automatically happens
and uh passive abilities something that
just adds to a stat or something and
then that's it it never really does
anything again other than just
permanently buff a stat and then i was
also thinking there would be active
abilities something you can do during
battle where you can choose an action
these would be like spells special
attacks things like that i'm going to
scrap the whole triggered thing because
that's too that just gets too
complicated and we haven't even built
the battle system yet although i'd
really like to i just feel like there's
no real point until we at least have
some abilities so we'll get to that real
soon all right so we're going to start
upgrading these character classes and
start adding some level trees and
depending on how much time we have left
after we build a few we might work on a
few other things all right well the
first thing that has to go is this macro
this is a this is a very cool thing you
can do in all but it's not really going
to work in the long run because our
classes are going to have level trees
and i was thinking of doing this
in one way where this may have worked
okay
but uh we're changing that so
this is probably going to be this whole
macro thing is probably going to be
something we do later for monsters as we
can make a bunch of different types of
monsters really quickly but for these
specific four main character classes
they're all gonna start to differentiate
quite a bit
so
it makes sense for them to have their
own thing going on
and that's really all we're gonna do on
this episode so actually i'm just going
to copy there's a history of this on
github so there's no need to keep
comments that's one of the things about
using version control
you know sometimes you see people keep
their own code
and just comment it out because they
think oh i might need to reference it or
use it later well with version control
you can just go on to github or whatever
it is you're using and just look at the
history and it's that easy so no need to
convolute your code with a bunch of
extra stuff like this
but for just a second
we will so uh we're just going to go
we're just going to delete all this
and we can get rid of these things that
say eat a new line
and there we go and now we actually need
to put the the real numbers back in here
let's build out cleric
fourteen three five one was what we
decided on those
class name
cleric
we'll still macro out some of this stuff
but we're going to change how these work
a little bit
just so it actually is functional
delete that one
leave those there for a second
and
all right so we have level up it levels
up our stats but also in our level up
this is where we want to do stuff with
our class trees so we're going to have
to change the way this macro works i
think we're just going to take this here
this whole first line of the level up
and
we'll put it
just like that well the main reason is i
want this bracket to be here like we
this level up override is going to stay
the same but
it's kind of confusing if
part of this is in the bracket part of
it is not because
we just want it to be
this little block of these three lines
of code and that will be fine
all right i think we can get rid of this
last one there
there we go so since we have it eating a
new line right here on this macro
it's going to
basically go it's going to take this eat
the new line there so it's going to and
it's going to take this one and this one
and the macro is going to be those three
lines of code and end right there so we
could still go level up and and do this
thing right here and
that will be fine
and down here what we want to start
doing
is building our class and also
a few other things here
the cleric
is going to use another point well
everyone's got hp so we're able to put
that in the player character delegate
these are things that all of them have
in common
so that's okay
and also i've decided there's really no
reason right now for us to use memory
and make the hp unique it sort of just
adds a little bit of convolution to the
whole thing because we're not going to
be using any of the features of the
unique pointer although
they are cool and have their effects
this is just too simple of a thing to
really be worrying about it
right now
uh
now i might explain later why i intended
that but for right now let's just go
hp
one
i think that's how we wanted it right
and we need to change this down here
just take off the whole unique pointer
thing
you know it's a kind of okay to be
unique pointer just
the potential of the null reference in
the checking of the error code is
sometimes a little
little overdone so
we're just trying to remove any
redundancy we can to simplify thing
simplify things this is going to be
point type is that right no it's well
typed okay let's make sure we cast these
it's not going to hurt anything too
badly if we don't because it's going to
implicitly
do it but we might as well
okay
that looks good on the delegate class
i'm going to go ahead and just collapse
it so it gets out of the way
i got our nice little macros there and
we need to add this mp pool to the
cleric so let's just do that below this
constructor here
we'll just go
point well
mp
now there's something else we could do
we could we could inherit another thing
like like caster here or something like
that
and say that the cleric is a caster
and that could automatically populate
things like this point well and maybe a
few other things to manage the mp
we're not going to do that yet but it's
possible we might move to that if we
find ourselves retyping a lot of this
stuff
so for now
we're just going to do it like this
pointwell
mp
and in this constructor we're going to
change this constructor a little bit as
well let's see mainly
we want to manually type some more of
this stuff we want it to kind of be like
how the level up is for now and just the
internal block of code
i don't like having these brackets in it
because then it sort of makes it
confusing about what's really going on
there
that's just a personal preference
obviously it works either way so i'm
going to put a bracket there
and a bracket there
and i guess we're going to actually need
to take this here too
and put it
here
i think that's going to be fine
uh where are we at okay we need to get
rid of this bracket here and here and
this last new line so now this pc
construct is it's just going to be these
three lines of code and that's really
just so we don't have to repeat it all
the time okay
and it'll look something like that and
then we can add cleric specific stuff
here
level up clerics
specific stuff here
and
that should be okay
now first of all we do need to decide
the base mp
so that is something we can maybe add
to the caster type specifically
uh but it might change based on
the different classes so let's just make
it for now static const another
well type
called base
mp
and we just need to decide what it
starts at
for
this character i guess we'll put used on
that
make sure they're unsigned
so and then we can just uh we could do a
very similar thing that we were doing
with hp
we can use this set max and increase
current just like we were doing on that
and we want to do those on construct
just like this here
so we'll do that except of course these
are mp
and we're going to use the base on that
and we don't need those
and oh we don't need this uh pointer
thing because they're no longer unique
pointers so it's just a dot
and it's going to be the same in our
macros up here too so we want to make
sure we correct that everywhere since we
got rid of those unique pointers
otherwise we're going to have some
compiler errors and maybe we'll just do
a quick search for hp and see if there's
anywhere else we
set that uh looks good i don't think so
oh wait we got some here
so actually we can just search
you just select hp and the arrow
hit control h uh it might be different
on your editor we can just change that
to hp dot and do a replace all and that
should take care of all of them
all right cool okay
just an oddity i should mention here and
this is a visual studio thing
anytime you make these macros
apparently the next line below it
it auto tabs over
even if i hit my
correct syntax it still
puts it
it still tabs it over and i was trying
to figure out how to change that it's
going to do the same thing for a level
up
even if you tab down another or enter
down another line it still wants to tab
the thing below your macro even though
there's no reason it should
the macro you know it's just three lines
of code there's no reason to be
indenting after all of that on the next
line it really makes no sense
it's like it thinks it's a
a new
function or something so i did some
digging around online to try to figure
out how to set this and i found a really
old answer from someone on the microsoft
team that basically said uh it's not a
bug that's how it was intended
they didn't really specify why but that
answer had a lot of down votes so nobody
really liked that answer i mean i can
delete it and it looks fine
but anytime i hit the auto format button
it's just going to put it right back
so just an annoyance we're going to have
to deal with if we're using this editor
and we're using macros
if you could fix that visual studio
that'd be great it's not a good feature
it's it's a feature that doesn't even
make any sense
uh but it's a minor thing overall it's
not going to ultimately hurt our code
any it's just going to look awkward all
right let's move on so we want to do the
same thing with the level up for this
max hp stuff
and it's just going to be a set max and
increase max on
those
uh just to make sure
that it actually increases and we'll do
the same we'll use the we use the max
or uh we'll just increase it by half the
base
make sure these are base and p on these
otherwise it's uh not going to scale
correctly we don't want the scale of
health all right so that looks good i'm
going to hit the format button and just
see what it does and yep
it's definitely tabbing those over
it's definitely a coding sin but
we're just going to deal with it and
move on for now
and uh
yeah it's going to have to do it
okay
and next thing we want to do here is
just
just integrate some level trees and some
abilities
now i think the passive ones we can for
now we're just going to apply whatever
the passive buff is if it's a little bit
of buff to strength or something now
i've got a few level trees worked out
that i
kind of just
came off the top of my noggin here i've
got up to level five for all the classes
of what they gain
and some of them some of them might work
some of them we might have to change a
little bit but we're just going to keep
this really simple
and well the level 1 stuff we're just
going to put in the constructor because
you're going to start at level 1 anyway
so it makes sense for that to be in the
constructor and the main thing i have
for a cleric getting at level one
is
they're gonna get some mp and they're
also gonna gain an ability to heal magic
spell so we need to figure out a little
system for adding spells and adding
active abilities which i'll work on here
in a second and talk all about all right
so let's build this level tree now we're
just going to use some some if
statements basically because when you
level up
you have a very specific level
you have a current level
and
so you get this new current level when
you level up and that's it it just does
one at a time now this is uh
just going to be a really basic way of
doing it so we're just going to say
current level
equals whatever it may be we're skipping
one
because we get all the one stuff in the
constructor
so this is all we're going to do for now
is just make a tree of these
now this is going to get really lengthy
in the code but
there's no real
problem with it other than that so
current level that equals two
we want to get our next ability now hold
on i had a first ability here too
and it is uh just like a heal spell we
want the cleric to start out at level
one uh with some mp and a heal spell to
actually use
so we're going to do something like in
this constructor sorry i'm kind of
skipping around here a little bit just
want to make sure the level one's taken
care of before we start doing level two
we'll do something like gain ability
and add that ability but this brings up
another point so how do we
how are we going to use these abilities
how are we going to select them and say
hey my actions accessibility
and that sort of thing and we got to
kind of think about the flow of the game
now in combat we're going to do turn
based so we can just assume that using
an ability takes your turn
and that should be that we what we don't
want to have to do at this stage since
we're keeping this simple is we don't
want to have to program in a bunch of
special features like we don't
necessarily want to give abilities that
say
stuff like
take an extra turn take two actions
or on your you know just stuff that's
going to convolute our whole system that
might be for a later date when we start
getting more advanced but we want to
keep it simple
right now so let's
just make an ability class and we're
going to build that in a header because
this is something we're going to
probably reuse a lot so let's make a new
item here
a header we'll just call this
ability and we just need to build up a
little ability system here
uh we can just use we could use a struct
or a class
we're gonna just stick with struct for
the moment we might change it later
but now let's think about this when you
have some abilities
you need to know some things about them
like they're going to have a cost
and they're going to have
they might have no cost that would be
fine and they're going to have a set of
things they do
and they're going to have a name let's
go ahead and get the name in here that's
uh
let's just make that a string so we can
make it whatever we want
string
so abilities are going to have a name
they're going to have a cost now we need
to decide how we're going to do the cost
uh we could just go something like
uh we could just make it an unsigned int
and
call it cost
so we could assume these will cost
mp
uh for now assume mp if there is a cost
and we could say maybe it's just a free
thing
that uh if it doesn't have a cost it's
just free
or something like that but we yeah we
might have to make some interesting
assumptions here what i'm kind of
thinking is okay if it's a spell it's
got an mp cost you're going to use it
every every time
now if it's a
just like an attack or something maybe
it doesn't have a cost but it has a
cooldown so you can't necessarily use it
every time
so the cost would signify the cooldown
in that case or maybe we want both so
let's just put both in here for now
unsigned and
cool down and this will be
number of rounds
and then you have to wait basically
before you can use it again
you have to wait before
using it again
so that might be good for the rogue and
warrior and and just abilities that
uh you know
don't have a cost but it would be just
20 if you could just spam their best
ability every single round so maybe
you want that cooldown to balance it
that's all i'm thinking there so we've
got a name because cooldown now we need
some sort of effect so how are we going
to do this effect
you know i guess another thing we need
here is we need a target so it's either
going to be an enemy or an ally target
or maybe it's going to be a global
effect
so there's going to be a couple
different ways of doing this
i think for now we're just going to say
well let's make an enum here let's use
the power of enum to say it has to be
one of these
enum uh we might change this later
and we'll just call this
ability target ability
target
and it could be let's see
uh we got the class here in class
and this is basically an enum is
basically a type
so that's all it's really going to be
and we need to assign it some potential
values and it can only be one of these
at a time as sort of the point of an eno
so it could target self
it could target enemy it could target
ally
and it could just be global
i guess we could have like an all
all enemies all allies type things but
you know honestly this is getting too
complicated let's just stick with enemy
ally and in that case there's only two
things
so we could even go with just a boolean
because that's going to use less memory
so let's just do that we'll change this
to an enum later but just so you know
it's possible
uh
targets
uh so i guess we just need to make this
clear
is
ally spell
so if this is false it'll hit enemies
only
uh if not
then it's gonna be for allies
who this targets
yeah that's good enough i i think we
i may have constructed in this list here
a few abilities that are definitely
self-target only
so
maybe maybe we actually do want that you
know
so but that's just kind of thinking out
loud there uh so let's put self back in
here cell
ally enemy good enough now you can do
just extra special stuff with enums if
you don't really know about them
definitely worth looking up and reading
them at this point
but basically
whenever we instantiate this variable
that we've created here called ability
target
it can only be set to three different
things self ally or enemy and these will
correlate
to
uh basically integers and the first one
always starts at zero unless you decide
it doesn't uh but by default it's just
gonna be
uh self is going to be 0 ally's going to
be one enemy is going to be 2 and that's
fine with us 0 1 2.
so let's put that variable in here now
ability
target and
we'll just call this target
and we do need an effect here and i
think for effect
you know it could potentially affect
health it could potentially add or
remove debuffs we're not gonna add in
uh buffs and debuffs just yet that'll be
something for a later date because those
will need things like durations
for now i think we're just going to
keep it real simple here
and
just add in an effect so what does it
affect well one thing we could use here
is we could use a stat block
uh
most of these are probably going to
affect health or damage
so that that doesn't necessarily work
the best because we only have these it
could work
if we say add the stats from this stat
block to that stat block sort of thing
but that's not always going to be the
best
thing uh we'll just go like this struct
ability
effect and
in this case we just want to
say what it does basically
so
let's just make a few things here
you know i think we might actually want
integer on this one
potentially because
we could
say uh
well
i guess we could we have to make some
assumptions here now let's stick with
all unsigned
for now
but we could say if it's targeting an
ally
and it is a
hp effect
it's going to heal
if it's a targeting an enemy and it's an
hp effect it's gonna take hp away
so we could do something like that
uh we will probably add more to this
later
but
i think we'll just stick with that for
right now just hp effects only i don't
think i have a whole lot of other things
on here i did have some things that
would involve buffing and debuffing
but we're not going to worry about those
for now we just want to get the gist of
this
is down
and in fact there's really only one
thing right here
we don't even necessarily need this
struct yet
but i think we're going to expand on it
later
so
uh
nah let's just
let's just say
we'll expand on it later when we need to
let's just do this so there we go we got
these fields
that's it
we could give them some default values
i'll call this like unnamed
if they don't name it
cost
will start it at zero
uh for no cost
and we'll cool down
i will assume everything's just a one
unless they change it uh one would mean
you could use it every round
and a target we'll start this out with
ability target
uh what do we even say i guess we'll
just do self
and a lot of times when people make
these they'll have the first one as like
none or something like that
we're just
not going to do that we're just going to
default to self if they don't say
and then hp effect
self might even be redundant but uh it's
okay because it kind of overlaps with
ally a little bit but itself just
implies you can't target your own other
allies only you
hp effect let's just start it at head
one so it does something now of course
we're going to want to fill this this
struct out every time we
set one of these up so it might make
sense to have a constructor with all
this stuff ready to go
so let's go ahead and do that real quick
let's put a little constructor in here
ability
and
yeah we'll do it like this
so you can pass in a string name
uh
unsigned and well this hp effect
we know could be stat type we just don't
have that in here yet
so let's just stick with these unsigned
ants
it's just a bit of a lengthy name to
type over an overland sign and i guess
we could also type u and
32t but then we need to include the c
standard thing
which might be in string two
standard n
a little shorter to type that
and let's be real we probably don't need
32-bit sign integers that goes to like 2
billion or something and we're not going
to go that high but
uh let's just it's fine
uh
cost and let's let's rename these a
little bit so this will be name
cost now we don't want these to be the
same name as these variable names so
let's just
do something like capitalize these
that'll be fine
that way we know they're
part of the actual one
hp
back we'll just do it like that
and that way we can use all lower case
here in this constructor
un32t
what's called cooldown cd i think
everyone knows what that is
uh and we'll go
ability target
uh
t you know which is called t
and then hb effect
all right well let's see this is a uh 32
there's a couple different ways we could
design this class now we could use some
of those default values like we had in
the other one which i kind of like the
idea of actually
but
any way you do it's probably okay
yeah hp effect
i'll just call this hpe
and there we go and now we can
construct these automatically on the fly
like
so name
name
will be cost
cooldown will be
cb
uh target
bt
and
hp effect will be hp
and nothing else needed so we'll just
leave brackets empty
actually getting a tag on there however
you want to do it's fine
but there we go now we got a constructor
where we can fill everything out with if
you want now the way it's going to work
is uh if you just default construct it's
going to have all this stuff
and if you
want to specify things in the instructor
you do have to
specify all of them
so we could do it you know like we did i
think in the previous episode with
equals here for all the default values
but
either way
it doesn't really matter a whole lot
just whatever
you decide
all right so
looks like we have an ability in mind
let's go back to the player character
let's go up to the top and include
ability now
include
ability about h
and let's start adding these on
so if a player character can have
multiple abilities
and all of them are eventually going to
have some kind of abilities
we're going to need to store all these
some way so we're going to use a vector
for that just keep it real simple
use that vector
another thing to look up if you you're
new and don't know about them
but basically we're just going to put
this down here under the player
character delegate since all of them are
going to have these eventually
standard
vector probabilities
called
well instabilities
abilities
and we can start filling this out
as we go
as they gain them we can just push them
back then once we're in combat we can
iterate through these and see which ones
are available and off cooldown and
display them to the end user
so let's go ahead and do that
so
now since this inherits they're all
going to have that ready to go
and what we can do here is just well on
construct let's go ahead and add the
heal
so let's go
uh abilities
dot we could use in place back to
construct it in place
actually like that here
place back now in place
as opposed to push back it'll construct
it in place so sometimes it's a little
more efficient
but
did i spell the strongly i need an eye
over here
uh it needs the constructor values so if
we use if we leave it blank it's just
going to construct a blank one
with all these defaults now we don't
want that we want to give it all the
stuff
so i'm going to go off of
what i have here here it's called
eel
uh see i've got more here
yeah and we need to
it actually gives us a little hint here
you can see it's got this
constructor stuff it needs a cost
we're gonna say it costs two
uh and we're also going to say the
cooldown is just one
ability target now we've got to use this
specific syntax
ability target to specify it's that
variable
and this is going to be ally in our case
and
hp effect how much is the heal for
well we got to decide an amount and we
also
we probably want to have the scale off
one of their abilities
so that might be something that we
actually want to
to do to say which one it scales off of
strength and agility based
so i like that idea let's go ahead and
add that in here
and so i'll just i'm just going to make
another enum right now
and
we'll call this
abilityscaler ability
scale or
yeah there we go
and we could say none or if it doesn't
scale off anything then we have strength
and we have agility and we have hint so
it could scale off of any of those
and we'll have to decide how it scales
maybe we could even add that to the
ability to how much it scales off its
particular ability but basically what we
want to do is just add that on in here
as well
this will give us just a little more
a play
for the future of uh you know when we
level up our character will actually get
stronger based on their stats because
it's going to scale the abilities
so just a kind of a cool thing we'll be
able to add in the future
and we'll just call this
uh
scalar
we probably also need to say how much it
scales
but we'll assume none
faults on this
ability scalar
nut
now of course we need to add it to the
constructor as well
so we'll just tack that right on to the
end here
ability scaler
uh uh we'll just call it s
and we'll tack that onto here
uh scalar
is gonna construct to s
and there we go so later when we run
calculations on these we can do that
and uh yeah we probably should have a
scale percent but we'll just assume you
know we've been assuming a lot of half
so maybe we'll just assume half on these
as well for whatever the scalar is
that that's going to be fine we'll stick
with that in our heads for now
and i think we're good there
and we just need to be sure to add this
so this is going to scale off intellect
it's going to have a base of 2
that should be fine
and ability
scaler
we're going to say
it
so there we go that'll add that to our
list of abilities
it'll have a cooldown of one which is
one round so you'll be able to use it
every round
capital okay it's going to have a cost
of two we're going to assume that's mp
and if it's zero or we're going to
assume it's not a spell
because there aren't going to be any
free spells
and there we go so that will add that
heal ability onto onto the list
and
another thing we can do i'm just going
to prep we are going to fill the rest of
these levels real quick but before that
i'm going to go to the main here
and we just want to say we're just going
to list the abilities so
i'm going to make another line here
and
well
since there could be quite a few of them
we probably actually want to start a new
thing here but let's put it at the
bottom
uh we're just going to do a for loop
and it's going to be called uh
well let's see if we want to get all the
abilities
one of those changes declare we haven't
built our wizard yet uh
in this new form
and we just want to basically have a
little test here to make sure they're
actually gaining the abilities
so we'll say 4
let's see p1
or uh
i will just call it pc we'll use some
auto since we are using the modern
version of c plus plus we can do this
uh pc and
uh with second opinions of this
differently
or auto ability by reference
we don't necessarily want to do it by
reference but if you don't do by
reference it's going to make copies
every time it goes through this loop
but by reference you could modify them
which we don't actually want to modify
them so let's uh let's not do that right
now
p1
dot
we're looking for abilities
how did i spell that let's take a look
here
make sure yeah there it is
player character has no member abilities
okay right so we gotta think about this
uh it's actually gonna be
dot pc
well uh this is a player character not a
player character delegate so we gotta go
off of
whatever's at this very bottom final
instantiation here which you see we have
pc class
so we could have a
we probably want a function that
actually does this
uh now for just displaying it for
testing purposes
it's going to be a little
a little awkward
because it's not something we
necessarily
want to do in the long run so we have to
kind of decide on uh how are we going to
test this so let me think here for a
second
okay so one thing we could do is we
could just expose it entirely and say
okay let's make
this return a vector
of abilities
a vector of ability
uh even by reference that we'll get a
copy for now and it's going to be kind
of slow but this is really just for
testing purposes
so essentially we're just exposing it
and don't worry i know this player
character is a little redundant someone
left a comment about that because it
kind of just does
what
everything does already but eventually
what's going to happen and i'll just say
this real quick is we're going to have
stuff like
equipment
and we'll have multiple of these like
head slot for example or weapon slot and
so
on weapon slot
and we might also have like buffs in
here and stuff and what we'll be able to
do
is just like when you go to uh i don't
know get all your stats and stuff
you'll be able to add these all together
so it'll be more like return this plus
uh head slot
dot strength or whatever yeah the dot
armor i guess this will be more relevant
for armor on that kind of stuff but
we'll also have to do null checks on
these and to make sure something's
equipped and we're going to assume like
if it's null nothing's equipped in that
slot you know there's all this extra
functionality we're going to be able to
add to this
and that's that's really going to be the
point of this whole thing is to just tie
all the aspects of the character
together
while this one up here is more about
uh just like
the base types
that every character has
and
we'll kind of go from there and uh we'll
we'll decide how to do that later
um
got to make some design decisions
because like we could put equipment as
part of this delegate
but also you know that stuff's going to
be in your bag slots too and stuff like
that
in which case we don't want it to really
do anything with the player character
we probably have a whole separate area
to handle that
and uh
yeah so that's kind of where this is
eventually going anyway let's get back
to this ability we'll just say get
ability
list
and it's just going to return
pc
class
abilities
that simple
since it's designed in this way it is
going to make a copy of it
and
that's our intention here because we
don't want whoever is getting it to
modify so that's
one of the points of always returning
copies in our case these are small
enough variables that
it's not going to really hurt anything
but yeah we wouldn't want people to be
able to get them and then
and then return
or uh and then modify them because they
would just be able to hack everything
uh all right so uh we want to get the
ability first so we'll go ability
all right let's use auto
abilities
equals
p1 dot abilities
ability list
that's going to get us our copy and then
we can get it right through that
i spelled abilities wrong here too
oh let's just do this all abilities
okay i can't spell all right and then we
can uh
for this one we can go with reference
because we already got a copy
we don't want to copy it yet again at
this for loop so we're going to use a
reference here
uh let's call this
a build
order again
and we won't go up all abilities here
essentially just a for loop here that's
going to go through all of them
and that should take care of it and i
spell it wrong i probably did there we
go
abilities i think that's spelled right
and all we want to do here is just do a
c out on each of these
and uh maybe we could say something
first like
it's above this for loop
we'll say
uh
abilities
just a little formatting here
and we'll make a new line and then for
every one of these we'll space it over a
few
make a dash
and then
say whatever the name is a build.name
and then a new line here
let's make it a character
and that'll be it for now that just
should just say all the abilities we
could since we have access to it we
could say more about it what it is and
stats and stuff
uh but let's just do name right now just
to make sure it's working okay so cleric
should all be built well enough to build
this
uh so we're gonna by default get this
heal ability have some mp
mp is going to be a little a little
tricky to work with because
this uh won't necessarily know if they
have mp or not so that's actually a case
for it to be a pointer
because we'll be able to
see if it's instantiated or not so
uh yeah let's go ahead and do that so
this point well
star mp
and on construct
say mp equals
new
point well
so maybe this is what i was thinking
with that unique pointer before
uh that'll just construct a brand new
one and then we can start doing this
sort of stuff now the hp is one case
because we always have it but mp is
another one because we don't necessarily
always have it
so
you know now i'm thinking about this
we're probably going to want to check
no matter what the class is if it has or
not so actually the mp might belong
better in here
like so
and we might just go back to using
unique pointers anyway so we don't have
to worry about the destructor and all
that
yeah let's do it i know we took it off
there but hey
now we see a point
of doing this
so let's go back to using
unique pointers and i know
i jump around a lot when i code that's
just the way
i do it
so i know that annoys some people but
uh
it's what gets the job done for me
i have to just
work on where my brain is going
sometimes so hopefully that's not too
frustrating for you guys to deal with
all right
hp
equals standard make unique
so we'll construct this one
automatically
and this is
a point well
and we'll construct it with a one
now notice that we're not going to
construct
the mp here we're going to leave this
one
to the delegate to construct if they use
it
so this way
and we'll correct some other things here
in a second let's go down a little bit
uh
this way we can do a lot of different
things
well we're to have to change these back
but also
in these
macros here we're going to be able to
do empty stuff as well
we're going to have we're going to be
able to have them here
and
this will only work
if the mp is not null
so we'll say if mp
just to make sure it actually exists
and then we'll set it
so that'll be a little bit of a
difference there
we're gonna need these new line eaters
here
there we go and we can do the same thing
down here
and this will all make more sense in a
second if it doesn't
i'll just go to f and p
i'll just make sure it's not null
okay let's do that new line
this new line this one
that one okay
tap these over
change it to mp
all right so one thing we need to make
sure we do is before we call this pc
construct
if it has it we need to put it right
here
like so
and then now we can get rid of all this
stuff
we still want the abilities it looks
like
but
uh we'll just put a comment here be sure
to
init okay uh
before
pc construct
macro
which uh you know it's kind of obvious
if you look at the code but it's a
little hint here now this is a unique
pointer so we can't just use new like
that we gotta go
make
unique
of the type point well
and we can give it their base amount
here so let's go ahead and grab that
put it in there
and this one we want to get rid of
because that is now in the player
character delegate so there we go
so there's a potential of an mp pool
there
but
we're gonna control
some of it actually within
where we start using the delegate so
pretty cool stuff there and we no longer
need these
because that is also going to be
automatic
in the macro here
but only if it actually exists so if it
never gets
constructed and set up it'll just skip
over those every time so just a little
little hack we can do there
all right and we're looking pretty good
let's correct anything else we need to
correct with the hp i think anything
that's hp dot needs to change back to hp
dash
all right there we go
and uh you know just to reiterate also
we're not trying to be perfect here
we're just trying to like get some code
experience in and learn some things and
practice some things so that's more of
the intention
rather than perfection or anything like
that we basically just want to work do
what we want play around with some
different options and stuff like that
all right so we got that heal
this doesn't do anything yet but
let's just
go to
our main again
and well okay before we go to our main i
guess
we need to forward
some mp functions like this get current
get max
so let's copy these lines down
and just turn
all the mention of hp
into mp
and make it work off that other
well here so mp
uh
boom
boom boom
stay the same
uh this one should be
now it's just going to call the get
current and get max on those
uh we got to take damage and heal but
i think once we start using abilities
that's when we'll subtract from the thin
people so we're not going to need
functions here
we're going to have to
figure out how they get used but that
won't really come into play until till
we start battling for now okay now that
we got those functions forwarded let's
go back to main
and let's just copy this hp line down
and change it to mp
uh and just put
this as mp
now there's something a little
hacky here so mp might be null
so we're going to have to put like a
case in here so let's end that line
and let's just make empty his own little
thing because we're going to need
to we're going to need to see if it
exists or not basically
so it's going to be
a little different than how the hp works
because of that
so we'll have to either
uh
yeah i guess we just need to change this
so
we need to make sure it exists because
if we try to return this and it doesn't
exist it's going to crash on us
so we're going to have to expand this
function out a little bit so let's
make some new lines here
and put a little logic in here and just
say if
you see glass dot
or uh
so if it exists we'll get the current
we'll just return the current
otherwise if it doesn't exist
we're just going to return zeros
so that that'll be fine for now
uh and i guess we'll cast it it'll auto
cast to the well type and we'll just
we'll just see if this all compiles
before we start
getting too fancy and same thing here
just do a check
do they actually have the mp if so
return them out max
else
and it just returns zeros that's fine
so there we go that should take care of
any potential bugs and that also means
that we can just leave this without
doing any extra logic here and they're
just going to be zeros if we have it no
mp
all right
so now we should have that all added in
we got magic points we got the potential
of spells
let's hit play and go ahead and just fix
any errors we have here let's see what
it's complaining about
uh let's see here
it's
complaining about type cannot convert
type
to point well okay let's go ahead and
hit build again
and we want to go to
the not to
well
one of these should have more info one
second
all right it's saying the constructor
for one of our point wells was
ambiguous
and i think that is because
let's see let's look at our constructors
here on the point well we have
one that takes nothing and we have one
that takes a current and max
and it must be something we did with the
mp
or with the hp here so let's just go all
the way up to our delegate
and just take a look here let's see we
got hp we got hp that looks fine
okay so we're only putting in one thing
here
uh it takes at least two otherwise yeah
it's not gonna know it needs a current
and a max
so yeah that makes a lot of sense
and if we go down here to our mp we have
the same thing going on we need both
because uh basically there was no
constructor in here that only takes one
so it's like what do you do it and so if
you get that ambiguous error on a
constructor could be that all right
so let's hit play looks pretty good and
here we have
the new cleric now with more stuff
so mp wait we got a setting 14 that's an
oops
uh we might need to fix uh we probably
have a variable name but everything
looks like it's going good strength and
electric agility is going up still armor
resistor zero we have abilities now
there's no level 2 ability being gained
yet but if we add something we'll see
that it will fill it'll show up on that
list so let's just fix any errors we had
here
i'm guessing somewhere here
we are just uh
yeah it's in these level up and
construct we're still we still have base
hp here obviously
that needs to be base mp on the mp
because
you know that makes a lot of sense
uh base and p base and p
now this kind of brings up another thing
because with this base and p being in
here
if we don't have
this
right here on some of the classes like
the rogue and the warrior later
it's gonna it's gonna
be
what's the word for it
it's basically going to throw an error
because it's going to we're going to
have some code in here that doesn't
reference anything it's going to it's
not going to have any idea what that is
so
basically we're going to need to put
this base mp and all the classes the way
we currently have it designed
which is somewhat okay
uh we could just say if they don't have
any we'll just make it zeros
and that'll be fine enough
because then it's not you know it's
it's not going to matter anyway so we'll
just assume that will be the design for
now just to keep it simple
all right and let's just gain another
ability
sure i haven't worked out on paper
but it's not really super relevant for
the c plus plus and design let's just
make another one here called
uh smite that sounds like a good
ability although i don't really want
damage abilities on the cleric uh we'll
just put one in here for demos sake
and we'll call this one
target enemy
takes uh scales off end we'll make it do
two damage so it's just going to be kind
of like
the opposite of heal
on enemies
uh
yeah that's fine and then we'll get that
at level two
and let's just make sure it shows up so
let's hit play here
uh take a look
and see that at level two
we now have heal and spite
and uh that's that's good
so you can see
that
now based on what we've designed here
to make the wizard
you would essentially do the same thing
take this
copy it down
uh name everything wizard
oh make sure we keep the cleric one
isolated
uh wizard
and change it to the wizard numbers here
uh 10 181
so is
10
1
eight
uh i'll stop the base agility of two
uh and basin b let's give the wizard a
little more like uh
give them 14 base mp
there we go and our abilities we're
going to be different let's put like
fireball or something
with fire bolts pretty classic ability
and let's make it do its cost costs less
but let's make it do
significantly more damage
than what the clerics one does
uh and target enemy on that so let's
copy that up there
and we need a level two ability
we could say
um let's see
we could just add another one we'll
maybe just put like ice bolts or
something
and we'll make it do a very similar
thing maybe make it cost a tiny bit more
and do a tiny bit more damage
like uh maybe six that's just for
example here
and everything else looks fine on that
really just going up the example that's
that's not what i have on this paper i
need to
probably rework it
here because on this list that i made
custom it does have some trigger type
abilities i got a little creative
and we're not ready to get that creative
with how everything's set up currently
but this will give you a good example of
how you can
can do this
so of course to gain the next one you
would just
put more stuff in this level up code you
could essentially put the whole level
tree in here
and you could even put multiple things
on a single level like like so and if
you're not gaining an ability at all and
you're just gaining a stat
you could put
that gain stat code in here
like
as well so maybe the rogue and warrior
and stuff just gained hp or agility or
stuff like that but for example we could
say okay maybe
uh the wizard also gets just a little
bit of a bonus something on level two so
we could say
like uh just mp
plus equals
what some some other amount just give
them a bonus one
and it doesn't like this plus equals
because we got a
uh well it's
basically a pointer
so uh okay we need to do uh
we need to add for the current
so we need to do like uh
yeah it gets a little it gets a little
convoluted because of how we have it as
a point well but basically we would need
to do this sort of thing
which is the one
so yeah we could do that i mean so the
point is you could increase your other
stats here
uh we could say add to intellect or
something
so in this case we're just going to add
one get whatever your max is
add one to it
and increase the current by
one as well
so that there will just
add one to your maximum pool and then
and give you one
in case you need to restore one so i
feel like that's a good thing to do if
you increase your max just
also give a little bit of whatever you
gained to your current pool
and of course we could do
let's just do one more thing in here
let's just say
we get a little bonus into level two
so that would just be going off the stat
types
so we're just going to look at how we're
doing all our stats
and uh we haven't increased stats
but otherwise
uh let's see it's it's uh our stat lock
our stat block is on our player
character delegate
and
it's just publicly available so we can
just directly access that one
yeah it's just part of it
so let's just look at our stat block
yeah we would just call well it is
private here
so the only way to actually do it is to
call increased stats
and it just does a plus equals so yeah
we could just call increased stats and
that would take care of it
increase
stats
and
you see it's all zeros by default
so
uh strength zero and elect let's give
them one
agility zero
i'm going off this name here it's super
small i don't know if you guys will
actually be able to see it
but uh yeah just filling out these
constructors and the rest are zeros so
they're gonna default to zeros but the
thing is with these default values
uh you have to fill out all the ones in
front to
get to it
so there we go
since strength is the first one we at
least got to fill that out
uh yeah just default value logic but
that'll give us one intellect at level
two and one
more oh mp
oops almost did
almost based off the hp that would have
caused some glitches so
there we go so now we should see at
level two we'll have ice bolt and our mp
should go up by an additional one
one more than the actual scaler
and we should get a bonus intellect
so let's go ahead and do that
uh let's see we got the cleric showing
there
let's just
uh it's underlying player character is
undefined do we have we must have an
error in our code somewhere
uh it doesn't look like it i think we're
actually good it's just uh
who knows what visual studio is doing
sometimes it just it just likes to
underline things let's change this to
wizard
now it is possible that i like
uh renamed something wrong cleric cleric
no
wizard wizard
yeah looks fine
who knows what visual studio is doing
it's got a mind of its own sometimes so
let's just hit play here see if we get
an error
looks like we just missed a bracket
so it does seem to actually be correct
and complain
uh we just have to find where we missed
this bracket is it in the level up code
i think it is
yeah
okay because yeah this if statement ends
there and then yeah we need one to end
the level up yeah that's all it was so
it uh it was correct
and there we go there's a wizard
level one the level two looks like the
changes are reflected correctly
intellect goes up by four naturally and
then we got that bonus one from our
level up at level two and uh you can
kind of see the point here and you can
extrapolate from here
uh i'm not going to put all the
expanding of the other classes
in this video but i might push some of
it
for
the warrior and rogue
but this should give you just like a
base understanding
of how to do some some level ups from
here and how to expand into mp
and some of the other logic we're doing
with pointers uh and how this np is
going to work
you know what we'll do at least one more
here on camera because i want to show
one
uh with the mp stay null so let's go
create the next one let's make the
warrior
and we're just going to use
the same code here
change that one to
oh we don't want to change the wizard
class because i skipped
this one over here
and i'm kind of thinking maybe we should
put these specific classes in their own
files again because this is just
becoming really large
but now we need to design one so
base and b we'll just make that a zero
because it's got to be in there
uh class names find delegate all right
let's
not construct the mp at all
uh and now we want some abilities
our abilities here are going to cost
zero but we're going to start having
cooldowns
uh let's just have like a i don't know
12 something power attack
let's just call power attack
enemy
how much damage does it do now here we
could do like
well four plus strength but in reality
we probably also want it to be based off
your weapon too
so we're kind of skipping over that
detail at the moment
and we're also not considering hit
chances but i do have a formula in mind
that we'll come back to later for
uh how attacks work and uh chances of
hit stuff like that so they'll get that
at level one
you know what maybe the warrior doesn't
get anything a level one maybe they just
get the power attack level two so let's
put it down here
and there we go
that should be good enough oh we need to
correct these
it was eighteen five two two okay so
let's keep that in mind there
eighteen
five
two
two
i feel like it should be six let's give
them a little buff we are looking a
little weak
all right
let's go back to our main
just change this to warrior for a second
hit play make sure it all works fine
with that same code
you can see he has zero zero mp
so later in our game code uh you know if
we once we make a real interface we can
basically just check that like if they
have zero and p
or if mp is null then just don't display
anything there or something like that
or we could even say that
uh that's a different type of
resource bar like rage or uh
energy or something so we can we can
play around with that later is the point
uh but you'll see no abilities level one
just as intended level two looks like we
gained that power attack
and uh yeah we
we are ready to like level up and then
you know
from here we could do all kinds of sweet
stuff and we could start making like
some game progress and you could get
that gratifying feeling of i leveled up
i got my new ability i can use all that
cool stuff is starting to come in all
through the power c plus plus hope
you're enjoying the episode i appreciate
all your guys support and you watching
and all that see you guys in the next
one
[Music]
you